ان معركه طوفان الاقصى هي معركه الكل
الوطني
الفلسطيني يقاتل فيها شعبنا بكل قواه
ومقاوم في خندق
واحد وان اي حديث سوى وقف العدوان عن
اهلنا ليس له قيمه في مسار هذه المعركه
التي ستتوسع يوما بعد يوم وتحرق هذا العدو
وكل من دعمه وسانده
واعانه وان اهداف العدو قد تكسرت على صخ
صمود شعبنا
ومقاومتنا فها هي قياده العدو
المتغطرسه تتجرع الالم وتغوص في وحل الفشل
والاخفاق فلا التهجير الذي يحلم به قاده
الحرب الارهابيون تحقق ولا التدمير
العشوائي حقق او سيحقق لهم سوى الخزي ولا
هم تمكنوا من استعاده
الاسرى كما سقط القناع عن هذا الكيان
النازي البغيض الذي ارتكب محرقه ضد
الابرياء
صنعت له عدوا ومقاتلا حاضرا ومستقبلا في
كل بيت فلسطيني وعربي ورسخت صوره الاحتلال
البشعه اصلا لدى كل حر في العالم